from Peter the Great to Vladimir Putin
Russian leaders have attempted to
modernize and mold the nation's judicial
system but legal and political experts
say that time after time they've
undermined the system by using it to
wage war on their political opponents
when they really care about something
they have no trouble using the law as a
blunt instrument forbidding criticism of
the war
forbidding people from gathering in in
in in numbers on the street all those
kinds of things are very very crude
instruments charges like Espionage and
treason are among the most powerful
weapons in recent years former U.S
marine Paul Whelan basketball player
Brittany Greiner and Wall Street Journal
reporter Evan gershkovic have all been
swept up by the Russian legal system the
Russian criminal justice system is
incredibly sticky once you're in it's
very very hard to get out while Greiner
was released last year in a prisoner
exchange Whelan is still imprisoned and
considered wrongfully detained by the
U.S
was detained in late March and accused
of espionage
both the U.S government and the journal
VM Italy deny the allegation and have
called for his immediate release here's
a look at how Russia's courts have
evolved but why many of its features
remain the same
Joseph Stalin presided over a period
known as the great Terror where he used
the law to eliminate opponents and
consolidate power there was a provision
in the criminal code and it was a crime
of anti-soviet behavior and the problem
was is that there was no crisp clear
definition of what anti-soviet Behavior
was and so it could be almost anything
historians say millions of Soviet
citizens were executed died in labor
camps or were starved to death under
Stalin after Stalin's death Soviet
leaders like Nikita Khrushchev abandoned
Mass Terror he and the other people who
were surrounding Stalin made a a
decision you know not written down
anywhere but a very clear decision that
this kind of mass Terror was not
productive but that didn't mean that
political arrests were over it just
means that they no longer took place on
a mass scale many trials were closed to
the public and although people who were
arrested were allowed to have lawyers
those lawyers had to be approved by the
KGB
when Mikhail Gorbachev came to power he
attempted to introduce reforms to the
legal system in 1989 Gorbachev changed
the judicial selection process so that
judges were no longer picked by the
Communist Party
he also instituted a jury system for the
most serious criminal cases
what he really wants is to fix the
existing system now he did this in a
very you know a kind of ham-handed way
it was destined to fail it was under his
watch that Nicholas danoloff a U.S news
and World bureau chief was arrested by
the KGB and accused of espionage
danilov had fallen into a trap set by
the KGB eventually he was released in a
prisoner exchange after the fall of the
Soviet Union there was a rapid shift
from a planned economy to a market
economy and Russia's first president
Boris Yeltsin backed a revamp of the
courts this led to sweeping changes
within the legal profession lawyers were
free to start their own firms and
specialize in certain areas of law in
1991 a constitutional Court was created
and in 1993 Russia adopted a
constitution that became the Cornerstone
of the legal system judicial review was
introduced for the first time meaning
the Constitutional Court had the power
to declare acts of the legislative and
executive branches to be
unconstitutional in 1996 Russia joined
the Council of Europe which gave
Russians the right to appeal the
decisions of their domestic courts to
the European Court of Human Rights
however Yeltsin still managed to go
after opponents using the courts but
there was a major challenge in this era
wealthy oligarchs the emergence of the
oligarchs brings a whole element of big
money into the courts which is never
never helpful right
um uh and and because in the Soviet
period it really wasn't that you would
go in and monetarily bribe a judge but
in the 90s that definitely happened
Yeltsin set the foundation for a
division of powers approaching
government but his successor
re-centralized power back to the Kremlin
in 2000 Vladimir Putin came to power as
president of Russia he forged ahead with
new reforms and his supporters credited
him with reigning in the power of
oligarchs he backed a new code of
criminal procedure that on paper gave
defendants the same rights as those in
the west however old Soviet habits
re-emerged under Putin he passed
legislation that Consolidated more power
in his hands one law eliminated direct
popular elections across the country and
gave him the right to appoint Regional
leaders in Russia if you control the
legislature then what is the law the
other thing that he he gets very good at
is returning to this idea of vague and
overbroad laws in 2012 the Russian punk
rock band Riot was arrested for
hooliganism after protesting Putin's
Growing Power they go back to a crime of
of hooliganism which is just a you know
who knows what that means and it can
mean anything they were all eventually
released then in 2020 Putin passed
several Constitutional Amendments that
Consolidated even more power in his
hands Putin dismissed the Prime Minister
and prosecutor General whenever he
wanted despite Decades of efforts to
evolve Russia's justice system Putin has
brought back authoritarian control and
many of the elastic aspects of the
Soviet era's justice system we're back
to this old Soviet trick of finding a a
eternally elastic law that you can just
you know can catch anybody